I love him and he knows I love him
Shannen Doherty gets emotional over Luke
Perry's health scare ET spoke with the
actress while on the red carpet at the
animal hope and wellness foundation's
compassion gala about her former 902 uh
no co-stars hospitalization last week
after reportedly suffering a stroke I'm
not gonna I can't talk about it I will
literally start crying but I love him
and he knows I love him and I'm in
contact and I am and it's nuke and he's
my Dylan he's gonna be he's gonna do
everybody just keep pausing wonderful
thoughts that's all I'm gonna say
incredible
I mean you know I've been a part of the
foundation for a while now I love it the
fact that you know mark heads it up and
Mark Scott like the greatest spirit and
always the best of intentions is
comforting from me as somebody who
supports it the fact that now my brother
is working with the foundation is being
honored tonight yeah I mean it's very
special when the when the Wolsey fire
was happening it was mark that I was
calling and Mark was meeting me and we
were getting through and we were saving
animals together and I think that that
bond to in ties you together right and
we rested a cat and she named the cat
Woosley
he's very happy now and yeah and and you
know we got Sean involved which is
phenomenal so I think the foundation the
the legislative arm is going to do
amazing impactful things for animals
that should be a part of
well you know that if everybody gives a
little then the world can change and so
yeah it's not a matter of giving a
little we are we are facing some
significant odds we are fighting
industries that are entrenched in
Washington DC they almost edged in the
marble of the Capitol building and it's
more as needed than just a little bit we
need to step up step up in activism step
up in our legislative efforts in writing
our congressmen and going to DC but we
also need to step up in terms of writing
checks to these organizations and making
sure that they have the financial power
to push back against these folks that
have been there for generations
[Music]